[Music]
on today's show we have some hard
conversations so watch out for the
little ears in the room we talked to a
woman who is really struggling with an
abusive ex
we talked to a woman who's trying to
navigate her brother who's a sex
offender
we talked to a foster parent of a young
little boy who's trying to connect stay
tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
hola may everyone close
hope you're doing well welcome to the
john doloni podcast
radio show internets whatever it is
we're doing the youtubes all of us
james why are you laughing
it's a previous conversation we had oh
still got you still got me
i've i could see james through the glass
i thought he was making fun of me
no
see i hear you're go i make everything
about me has nothing to do with me my
wife tells me that all the time too and
kelly it's not about me
even though the show's got my face on it
whatever dude
kind of is is it it's not
no look right behind you
oh my gosh that was awesome i like how
you just did that
look behind me hey thank you so much if
you want to be on the show
1-844-693-3291
go to
johndaloni.comask and by the way
conversation carts are out you can go to
johndeloney.com and order them there's
three different packs cards for how to
talk to someone you're on a date with
how to
uh talk to your kids
and man conversation cards for all
generations you can sit around a table
at christmas or at thanksgiving no
politics questions no coveted questions
just like man
how are you growing up and questions
like that they're pretty rad i'm getting
some incredible feedback get on the
internets and get them ordered so they
can get delivered to your house asap
let's go to kayla in denver colorado hey
kayla what's going on
hey it's good to talk to you it is even
better to talk to you what's up
okay so um oh that was a big deep breath
big breath it's it's been a lot oh
what's up so
oh i'm already gonna start crying that's
okay that's okay welcome to the gang
thanks
um
i
was in a very abusive relationship um i
got out
out and away and safe
about eight
eight and a half years ago can i stop
you right there for a second
yeah that is still fresh on you
yeah
um we share a child so he's not
he's not completely gone but
so your body has to re-experience that
bear that tiger
every day
yeah and once a week or whatever
drop-off is man i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry thank you what type of
abuse
um
everything
um it started off mental and emotional
um it turned into physical
um
he i mean he would take my money so
there was financial there too
i'm so sorry and so i finally got away
when he
um
he tried to kill me while i was holding
our daughter
so um
wow
i left
good for you good for you wow
yeah thank you
so eight years ago and here we are how
can i help today yeah
well
um so he's he's done it again to
somebody else
and big shock huh
yeah shocking
uh yeah um but
so
the assault on me when i left was a
strangulation and he strangled this lady
too
and she's come to me for help she has
she also shares a child with him
um and so it's caused a whole bunch of
you know upheaval
i had filed with the courts to restrict
his parenting time with my daughter so
one of my questions is how to talk to
her about that because she's
confused and misses her brother and
this other mom
and then
the other question i had was how do i
help this mom without re-traumatizing
myself
who what a mess
this guy sucks huh
he knows i'm sorry man
wow
hmm
so
yeah man
unfortunately
i'll answer your second question first
unfortunately i
you
i'd stay away from this mess
and
it sounds like you are a person whose
heart
is beating in sync with this other woman
you know what she's been through you
know what the last eight years of your
life have been and nobody walked
alongside him with you and you want to
reach out because you're a good person
you're an empathetic person you love
people
and what i'm gonna tell you is you're
gonna get covered in other people's crap
and there is not a good
winnable solution there's no reason to
participate in this chaos
okay because you found out somebody else
that your husband is not a safe person
that he's got a pattern of physical
violence
um you did the right thing by filing
with the courts that i'm not i don't
want my daughter around that because
just a matter of time before she gets
teed up to be the next victim
so good for you
but
i would draw a pretty strong hard
boundary between you and what they've
got going on in their crazy world
okay
she needs to
obviously get support she needs to reach
out she needs to get away from that
lunatic and she needs to file the right
restraints so that she can protect her
son
but that's her responsibility not
yours okay
and i know that's hard
and there's something about
purpose and there's something about i
don't say revenge but kind of and
there's something about
finally i'm strong enough eight years
later and now i'm coming back for you
and what i'll tell you is that whole
scenario ends up in everybody in ash
okay
am i right
yeah i mean it kind of feels that way
she um
she's trying to get away and she's
you know contacting me
help me help me i don't know what to do
and
call 911 anytime i would let her know
every time you call me i'm going to call
9-1-1
okay and every time you call me i'm
going to call 9-1-1 every time you call
me because they are the folks who can
help you i cannot
i'm not going to put myself and my baby
girl in his position of either me being
killed
which he tried before and my daughter
not having a mom anymore and a dad in
prison
i'm not gonna put myself in a situation
where
i i don't belong
right and the right thing to do when
somebody calls and says i'm being abused
and i'm not safe is i'm going to call
9-1-1 every single time i'll call on my
friends if one of my buddies wives
called me and said hey so-and-so is
beating me up or do i'm calling 9-1-1
i'm getting the police involved
because that's their job
okay and life is not a john wick movie
right right
um as as it relates to talking to your
daughter
how old is she now eight nine
yeah she'll be nine in january okay does
she know anything about your past or
your history or about dad
no he um
so
when i left he stayed gone until she was
four
and
then
had
weekends with him but no overnights
because he was a flight risk and then
um
now she's down to
one hour a week at a supervised facility
yeah so
i mean she
she has a context for
my interaction with my dad is different
than my friend's interaction is with
their dads right
yeah have you ever had the conversation
with her that dad is sick
um
we've been teetering on it here
lately
yeah it's time for that conversation and
um
whether you all have a family counselor
that you work with
or
you've got another family friend here's
what i want
sometimes when we have a hard
conversation with our kids
they immediately shift into fight or
flight
and because they get there there's kids
grown-ups do it too
but they we shift into they shift into
am i going to be okay
and what did i do
and so often we can have a hard
conversation with our kids and they will
never circle back to us
and ask the follow-up questions
and that's why i'd love to have a either
a counselor or a friend or a
somebody that
not a a not a nine-year-old friend but
an adult friend a grown-up friend an
aunt an uncle a cousin somebody that
that your daughter trusts
that will loop back and be able to ask
questions
or
you plan for the next two months every
saturday morning i'm gonna do breakfast
with her i'm going to move work around
we're going to figure something out
but i'm going to set up a context
so that we regularly interact with one
another we regularly talk about stuff
together
and eventually those questions will come
up does she feel safe talking with you
about things like that or is a little
bit weird
um i think it's a little bit of both i
last night she came into my room i need
to talk to you and i've really been
working with her
especially here lately on you have to
tell me things
you have to come talk to me it's
important that you feel like it's safe
to come talk to me okay
stop right there stop right there that's
a really important distinction
okay okay
your job as mom
is to create the safe environment
forcing a nine-year-old to talk to you
about something where she doesn't feel
safe is is is akin to violence
okay it can feel abusive
so when i look at my tenure or my son's
11 if i look at him and say you must
come talk to me
and then i don't create a safe world for
him to come talk to me or where i'm
gonna gonna give him five hours of
lectures or i'm gonna ground him for
talking to me or i'm gonna
make fun of him for whatever
i am forcing him
into an abusive situation
so okay instead of saying you have to
come talk to me
i want you to say
i want to be a safe place for you
maybe i haven't been in the past maybe
i'm going to continue to work on that
um but you have to tell somebody
and here are two or three people that
are safe for you to talk to your school
counselor aunt jane and me
and i want to give my kids an option i
want them telling somebody but if their
option is
telling an unsafe person which just
happens to be me
or
nobody they'll pick nobody and their
bodies will respond for the rest of
their lives
okay okay
so
the best way to do this is to start a
regular breakfast club with your
daughter
breakfast dates y'all can get dressed up
you can get dressed down you can only
wear pajamas make it a little bit wonky
and a little bit unique for just y'all
okay
it can be you're gonna get her one piece
of fancy chocolate or ones just
something where it's a little bit
special
and commit on your calendar for the next
two months i'm going to not miss a
saturday
we're going to do this i'm not going to
miss a sunday we're going to use every
single week
and we're just going to chit chat
what's going on in your world what's
going on in my world what are three
great things i'm gonna bring some
coloring books we may just sit at
cracker barrel and color together and
not say much in anything
but she will begin to feel connected to
you and you will hopefully feel not
not say but feel safer
okay and it is time to have the
conversation
the reason your daddy doesn't need to go
into the abuse
but daddy is sick
and daddy can be unsafe
that's why these arrangements are the
way they are
and little brother
little half brother
he's going to be entering into the same
situation soon as well he is going to
also be um
moving away because his mommy is not
safe either
not that dad's a bad guy because your
daughter is half dead and if dad's a bad
guy then half of her is a bad person
it is about dad's actions and dad's
behaviors dad is not well
and sometimes daddy is unsafe
and my one job is making sure you're
safe
and you still love daddy and daddy still
loves you
he just finds himself
unable to control his behavior or
choosing to not control his behavior and
he is unsafe
and any any question like why how how
come it i don't know honey
all i can do is love you
and create a safe space for you
let's get a cinnamon roll right or maybe
not eat cinnamon rolls but whatever it
happens to be
don't force your daughter to
talk about things she doesn't feel safe
about
give her options and create safe
environments for her
create safety
it might be that you have an opportunity
to model for her
and give her a great gift
and teach her how to grieve
teach how to be sad
i'm sad that daddy's not safe
i would love more than anything for you
to be able to run and play with daddy
and it makes me sad
and it's okay to feel sad
and when you teach her that and you give
her permission to feel and you model for
her what feeling feels like what looks
like
wow what a gift
what a gift
she's lucky to have you kayla but get
out of that other mess not your circus
not your circus we'll be right back on
the dr john delaney show
[Music]
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john de loni show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john deloney's show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
we are back record jack let's go to anne
in colorado springs what's up ann
hi john how are you remarkable how are
you
i'm doing well outstanding what's up
my brother is a registered sex offender
do i let him see my children at family
events
what do you think
no
ta-da
so
i have a very large very close-knit
family i am one of six children
all of my siblings are married we all
have children and we
get together and see my family my
parents
at least once a month
um and what did your brother do
he
to join this illustrious list
okay so he was arrested when i was still
in seventh grade so a long time ago okay
for statutory rape on a minor okay
uh he was charged and he spent
a couple years in prison
and then he fled
and then he got rearrested and
extradited back to colorado
and spent a couple more years in prison
so we haven't seen him in a very long
time
but my parents have seen him a couple of
my siblings have seen him
and my parents are really pressing
because he just got to a point in his
recovery where he is allowed to see
children
if the parents of the child approves it
so my parents are really pressing so
that he can come to family events what
are your brothers and sisters views on
this
it's about half and half
um a couple of us
can't do it because of our professional
jobs won't allow it
a couple of us just don't want to
because of personal reasons what do you
mean your professional your professional
jobs won't allow it
uh
one of my brothers is a parole officer
or not a pearl officer a uh prison guard
so he can't be in the presence of a sex
offender
i did not know that look at you teaching
me things and
um yeah so
this
when i
when i first hear the word statutory
rape i think of an 18 year old dating a
16 year old this is not that
he was
21 or 22 when she was 12. there you go
that's a child
that is a child so statutory rape sounds
different than that that to me is
sexual abuse of a child
yep
um
and the fact that he's been in jail for
this long and is still on a recovery
plan tells me that things aren't haven't
gone well
yeah he uh he had a lot of trouble at
the beginning of it i wasn't fully
around because i was also 12 when this
all happened so i wasn't really involved
until i was an adult i didn't know what
happened i just knew my brother just
appeared for a while yeah was it one of
your friends no but she went to school
with me i didn't actually know her but
she went to school with me and was in
the same grade okay
so here's the honest truth
you have a you know
and so your question is less about
well now i sound like an idiot uh being
some guy telling you what you feel and
think so i don't want to be that guy
here's what it sounds like to me tell me
if i'm right or wrong
it sounds like your question is not
about whether your
brother
who has a proclivity for sex with
children should be around your children
or your brothers and sisters your nieces
and nephews
it sounds like you're struggling with
trying to participate in fulfilling your
parents fantasy that everything is going
to be back the way they had always
dreamed it would be
yes
that seems like what's on your mind not
whether your brother should be around
your kids
yeah and breaking it to my parents that
it's not the right thing to do for all
of us right
so
if there's consensus among the brothers
and sisters
then you can appoint a spokesperson you
can all have this meeting together you
can write a joint letter etc
that's the best way to do it
if you have brothers and sisters that
are that don't believe like i think
brother's all better it's gonna be great
i'd love for my kids to see their uncle
and then there's two or three or four of
you who are like you're crazy
um you you all can circle up that way
i would recommend if there's a break in
rank meaning there's some brothers and
sisters who are in some who are out i
would speak for me and my family
okay
and
this is gonna require hard conversations
but i want you to remember this
your responsibility
is to keep your kids safe
your responsibility is not to make your
brother feel better
or
your responsibility is not to make mom
and dad feel better
and your responsibility is to not to
make this fantasy of the full family
come true
your one job on planet earth is to keep
your kids safe
okay and if two years five years ten
years from now
you decide i'll i will
sister
i will re-engage my brother on my terms
and then after five ten fifteen years
i determine
or one year it's up to you
he's safe
then maybe
but given what you just told me not
around my kids no i have an 11 year old
i have a five-year-old no chance zero
chance yeah
and
i actually would put it back on mom and
dad
if you are choosing
to allow your son to come into these
things you are also choosing to not have
your grandkids around
because they will not be
and so really this choice here is not
yours it's your parents
and they need to
bear the full weight of this and not
pawn this choice off onto their daughter
does that make sense
yeah
and i know that i want you to shift like
thank you for handing me this brick i'm
handing it right back to you this is not
mine to carry this is y'all's choice
here's my boundary and hopefully your
brothers and sisters will join you in
that
and then your parents will have a hard
conversation i have a hard choice to
make
yeah and i don't i i can't even imagine
what they're going through it's probably
a nightmare
yeah
a nightmare for many many years yes and
the nightmare is gonna continue because
there's no more
now there's not a jail holding it back
it's gonna have to be them or they're
gonna say come on back
lost prodigal son and then they're gonna
lose four of their other children and
all their grandkids
yeah
and so this thing is a mess it will stay
a mess
your job is to make sure your kids are
safe
okay
and to make sure when you do have this
conversation with your parents however
hard it would be treat them with dignity
and respect and honor i they are in a
hard spot but this is a simple simple
simple
call for me
if i'm your mom and dad i would talk to
my son say we're so glad you're
continuing your program
can't wait till you get out
we do have a family full of 50 or 60
little
munchkins running around here
a bunch of grandkids everywhere
and
as the
senior mom senior dad of his family we
are not going to put you in a position
to compromise our family to put make
kids unsafe and have any sort of
question
about you
coming to come into play we're going to
keep everybody safe including you
brother just getting out of jail
and so we may have an adults-only dinner
sounds great
[Music]
or we may
um do a special
you know christmas morning or christmas
afternoon with just the three of us
but we are not gonna put our grandkids
in that position we're gonna put our
other um sibling other children in that
position we're not gonna put you in that
position that's what i would
but again who knows thank you so so much
for a call go with your gut you know ann
oh you know
your kids are lucky to have you we'll be
right back on the dr john dolan show
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back
listen if you're about to buy a home and
make a big change save yourself the
headache and call churchill mortgage
today at triple eight loan 200. trust me
that's triple eight loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right let's take unimas let's go to
alan in sioux falls what's up alan how
are we doing my brother
i'm doing well i'm outstanding what's up
i and why am i yelling i don't know i'm
yelling i'm just kind of excited i had
too much coffee today
i'm just gonna dial it back about 40
percent ready
hey alan what's going on man you doing
all right
yeah
excellent there's no reason for me to be
louise
my wife and i are
foster parents and
we have
a seven-year-old just about
seven-year-old boy and a four-year-old
girl
wow yeah y'all are awesome alan awesome
thank you um the seven-year-old boy
is
struggling to
well connect with
males
right or even boys his age
his uh friends
at school are all girls
and
[Music]
i
haven't been able to connect with him i
also struggle with connecting with males
but i do have a couple real close
friends
but he seems to not be able to
really connect with them at all okay i
was wondering how i could help him to
be able to do that man
well number one again you and your wife
are awesome and this little boy is lucky
to have you stepping into his world um
when you say he's unable to connect with
males what do you what do you mean
is he uncomfortable around him has he
been abused before has he gotten beaten
up in another home like
is he just
think things other places are funnier i
mean
where is he
so there's been nothing
actually confirmed but they're suspected
that there's been some abuse okay in the
past um he's also never had a male
in the house
generally he grew up with a single mom
who's
made poor choices with
men and stuff like that another thing
too so so without talking to him i can
only conjecture i can make something up
okay
right
my
gut tells me
that in his seven-year-old brain
men are not safe
men are scary
and men disappear
they go away they go away
men hurt my mom
men make me scared
and so
i his little brain is telling him 24 7
365 to stay away from that tiger because
that tiger bites
and
maybe his mom was a place of peace maybe
he had sisters maybe he had a babysitter
maybe he had an aunt who knows but women
are safe and so
first out of the gate when it comes if
he's connecting with somebody i want to
i want to be happy about that
um sometimes it's as simple as getting
kids involved in little league or in
like activities kind of things where
he's going to have to be around other
little boys like soccer or whatever and
make connections that way
um i i wouldn't so much force that or
think there's some sort of problem
um unless he starts saying i'm scared
or i just you know i mean does he do any
sort of activities does he play sports
anything like that
uh we did we did soccer and we do church
uh soccer kind of
it was
all right in church he does have a
couple older boys that he
plays with but generally it's their
sisters that he plays with okay
um have you invited some folks over for
some
just silliness and fun
uh not for a while okay
any reason or just just just because
the world's busy
the world's busy okay okay
so what does he love what does he love
to do
um
he
he loves playing he loves kicking the
soccer ball and running around and
all that kind of stuff he
he is
so we have a 18 month old daughter and
his four-year-old little sister
and
he doesn't know
when to stop and tend to hurt people not
out of like malicious he just
he's bigger than them
and
so we have to reign him back a lot when
he's playing and doing stuff like that
sure and some of that's just him
learning his own body right right um
yeah and making sure he can he responds
to other people's
personal autonomy right
and
every parent tells their son hey that's
their body and when they say stop then
you stop right so that's a lot of it's
common stuff
um so here's here's a couple of things i
would pass along to you
number one
i'll tell you what just happened in my
house
i got to a point where
i could tell
that my five-year-old daughter tensed up
every time i came into her presence
and i hated it
because she's five and that means i'm
the problem
something about the way i was entering
into her world
not her in the mind but me into hers
caused her to flinch
and i'm loud especially early in the
morning i like getting up early and i'm
excited about the day and blah blah blah
i'm a lot that's what my wife says
i also like really loud music i like
dancing around in the mornings and i
like going to bed early all those things
so here's a an adjustment i made
well i would come i'd see my daughter in
the morning and i'd say good morning and
she would just put her head down to
which i would say you have to say good
morning back we're respectful in this
house and she would say
good morning
or i would force her into a situation
where it was me versus her and she will
double down
and double down and double down because
she's her mom
and so she'll just go down with that
ship
and then i find myself acting like an
idiot
so i just completely switched tactics
because i know my daughter loves me and
i love my daughter
so she loves to color in the morning
quietly so you know what i did i just
got some markers and i sat down and i
got my own coloring book and i just
started sitting down in the mornings and
coloring and not saying anything
other than good morning
and wouldn't you know it five minutes
later we are laughing carrying on being
silly making jokes
she just needed five minutes of
quiet
stress-free dad can you dial it back 30
connection
i entered into her space gently
and so here's what i would tell you
find things that your son loves kicking
a soccer ball
playing
chicken with the tennis ball out on the
side of the house running around in the
woods going hike whatever it is
and you enter into that space
find connection with him what does he
like what does he love what does he
enjoy
and meet him there
because what you're doing here is you're
establishing safety and every time you
want to connect what parents often do
especially dads is we ask our kids to
come to our world
and for a kid who's been in his
situation that's not safe his brain is
telling him it's not safe
and so he may be with you
in doing whatever it is you want to be
doing anyway
but he is not connected because his
brain is
trying to fight or flee or freeze
when you enter into his space it's safe
there
yeah and so find spaces where you can
enter in and then here's another one
that my friend nate taught me he's a
he's an
expert working with kids he's a children
author he's just awesome
the greatest gift you can give your
young child is to
bring them with you when you hang out
with other grown-ups so they have a
picture in their head of what friendship
looks like
and so
the rule is with most of my friends is
wherever you go unless we're going to
like a bar to watch the fights wherever
you go our kids are coming too going
hunting kids are coming going fishing
kids are coming going to do some work at
your house kids are coming
and they're going to get a real life
picture of what friendship looks like
and your your foster child should have
got that from his dad and he didn't
and he should have got that from his mom
and he didn't and so the great gift you
can give him is to hang out with your
male friends and to bring him along
and that puts all of this i hope you
hear me saying this all of this
comes back to alan not to this little
boy does that make sense
yeah
does that sound crazy or is that
something you can do
that's something i can do it
a lot of
what i've been kind of trying to do
except i've been bringing him into my
world instead of entering into it
love it love it bring him into your
world when you're hanging out with your
friends
right because he needs to see that even
if it's unsafe for him
slowly over time he'll see it he'll see
y'all laughing he'll see y'all carrying
on he'll see you throw and nail one of
your friends with a racquetball he'll
see y'all throwing water balloons at
each other or he'll see you all fixing
each other's cars together he needs to
see that and over time his brain will go
oh these are safe interactions these are
okay
and then when it's just y'all too
you enter into his space i love that
love that love that and going back to
the busyness of the world
the world is busy man i'll tell you it
is so busy i'm tired
i got too much going on i'm tired and i
know you're tired too
i had to have a reset this weekend i got
back in from a trip man in one week i
was in florida and i was in nashville
then in florida then back in nashville i
was in salt lake city and then i had to
stop in texas and i'm back and then i
leave tomorrow to go to san antonio if i
got one more trip for the next month i
think
i got book deadlines dude i'm so tired
and
my kids didn't sign up for this
i signed him up for him
so i got to be intentional about my
connection
i got to be intentional into entering
their spaces
making sure they know they're loved that
they're safe
and i gotta be intentional about saying
hey i gotta leave town or i'm gonna go
work on this thing and
you just have to go find stuff to do you
gotta be bored that's fine
but i gotta reach into their world
i gotta be intentional about it
that means i have not watched a single
nfl football game this year not one
not one i've not watched a college
football game this year
i've missed some fights and i never miss
fights ever
i've been to a concert it's killing me
because i've got limited time and i'm
making sure i'm intentional about what
they get next and your kids are worth
more than a football game whatever other
stuff we got going on
the kids are lucky to have you alan man
they're lucky to have you
blessings to you on this adventure thank
you so much for the call as we wrap up
today
man
trying to lean in like we're just
talking about enter into our kids world
i think i've talked about this on this
show my son is obsessed with
90s and early 2000s country music
you know those incredible guys brad
paisley and that dude can smoke a
telecaster
and he's a great songwriter
so i was just driving by myself
listening to my brad paisley cds
this is off the 2007 album fifth gear
this is so great
it's called ticks and it goes like this
every time you take a sip in the smoky
atmosphere you press that bottle to your
lips and i wish i was your beer
and in the small there of your back your
jeans are playing peek-a-boo i'd like to
see the other half of your butterfly
tattoo
hey that gives me an idea let's get out
of this bar and drive out into the
country and find a place to park
because i'd like to see you out in the
moonlight i'd like to kiss you way back
in the sticks i'd like to walk you
through a field of wildflowers
i'd like to check you for ticks is that
not a redneck man brad paisley makes my
heart so happy
brad i don't want to check you for ticks
but i kind of feel like this is what we
do on this show
check each other for ticks right here on
the dr john dolone show
[Music]